جزر المالديف هي أمة محيطية
[موسيقى]
أكثر من ألف نوع مختلف من الأسماك
تعيش في هذه البقعة من المحيط الهندي
أحيانًا وبأعداد كبيرة
هنا في جزر المالديف لدينا أكبر
عدد من أسماك شيطان البحر التي
تم تسجيلها على الإطلاق في
العالم الذي تتواجد فيه  يقود 5100
فرد في قاعدة البيانات
بيث فولكنر فريقًا من
الباحثين في مؤسسة مانتا تراست
الخيرية للحماية
ستة أيام في الأسبوع لأكثر من نصف عام
تتوجه هذه المجموعة إلى
خليج محمي تابع لليونسكو على أمل العثور على مانتا
للدراسة
ومن المدهش أن هذا الطقس هو
الطقس الذي يرغبون فيه
في موسم الأمطار ، ستحاصر العوالق
في نهاية الخليج المغلقة ،
وبعد ذلك ستأتي المانتا لتتغذى
على هذه العوالق المحبوسة هناك ،
ويعتمد ذلك على التيارات والرياح ، لذا
فنحن بحاجة إلى أن تكون مثالية
.  لا أرى أي حشائش يمكنني رؤيتها
في المياه الضحلة ،
نعم ، هناك بعضها في المياه الضحلة ،
لذلك وصلنا للتو إلى خليج عسل الموالية ،
يمكنك رؤية المانتاس هنا على السطح.
eady لذا فهم يتغذون بالفعل وهو
أمر رائع بالنسبة لنا
بمجرد أن يكتشف الفريق موضوعاتهم ،
فقد حان الوقت لإلقاء نظرة فاحصة على
أسماك مانتا راي هي كائنات مهيبة حقًا
وهي معروفة بالعمالقة اللطيفة ، لذلك
ليس لديهم أي لدغة ولا أسنان ولا شيء هم
يمكن أن تفعله لإيذاء
البشر ، يمكن أن تصل أشعة مانتا الشعاب المرجانية التي تتغذى على
العوالق الشبيهة بالجسيمات المحيطة
إلى أربعة أمتار ويصل وزنها
إلى 700 كيلوغرام
اليوم ، وهي تعتبر من الأنواع المعرضة للخطر
مع انخفاض عدد سكان العالم
بشكل أساسي بسبب تدهور الموائل
i '  لقد كنت أعمل مع mantas منذ عام
2017 وعليك أن تقضي الكثير من الوقت
مع نفس الموجهين ،
وأعتقد بالتأكيد أن لديهم جميعًا
شخصيات
مختلفة وهذا شيء نأمل
أن يبحث عنه الناس في المستقبل
في الوقت الحالي ، حيث يجمع فريق بيث البيانات
عنهم  تمت دراسة العادات السلوكية لحجم السكان
وأشعة مانتا للتكاثر فقط لما
يزيد قليلاً عن عقد من الزمن من الناحية العلمية ،
وهذا ليس طويلاً ولكن لا يزال هناك
الكثير  التقديرات التي لا نعرف
إجابات لها ولا يمكنك إقناع
الناس بحماية شيء لا
يعرفون الكثير عنه
حتى الآن ساعد عمل الفريق في
توفير حماية قانونية للموئل
لمانتا وإدراجها في جزر المالديف.
قائمة الأنواع المحمية
إذا لم نتخذ خطوات لحمايتها
الآن ، فلن يظلوا هنا لفترة
أطول حتى تتمكن
الأجيال الأخرى من رؤيتها والمواجهات
التي أجريها ، أود
أن يكون لدي أكبر عدد ممكن من الأشخاص
[  موسيقى]